good life lurk in Hidden oceans on
Jupiter's moons
a juice mission is finally on its way to
find out
launch was an anxious moment in Imperial
College in London scientists here built
and will operate one of the mission's
key instruments
to happen we had to wait another day
it's finally gone I was so happy to see
it this way it's a beautiful Village
it's a real moment of excitement and
relief for the scientists involved
because the mission's finally on its way
and for the European Space Agency that's
never sent a dedicated mission to
Jupiter 4 before and certainly not one
with as many scientific instruments on
it as this it's very much just the first
step on a very long and perilous Journey
all the way to the Jupiter system
the Jupiter icy moons Explorer is
embarking on an eight-year-long four
billion mile slow waltz through the
solar system several orbits of the Sun a
slingshot around the Moon and Earth
another around Venus needed to get it to
Jupiter in 2031. once it arrives it will
perform flybys of Jupiter and three of
its moons Europa Callisto and Ganymede
some as close as 25 kilometers to the
surface
foreign
ERS here at Teledyne in Essex they made
the Imaging sensor induces camera No
Easy Task as radiation around Jupiter
would destroy conventional Electronics
the environment it sees at Jupiter is
nasty especially really really high
radiation so there's a high probability
of anything ordinary will fail and the
in launch environment is quite nasty as
well so you've got to make sure it
survives launch survives the journey
there and it continues to work well in
the horrible environment that's around
Jupiter it is very exciting and
especially when it's the first image of
something that's never been imaged
before
other tools Radars and magnetometers
will peer into the ice covering
Jupiter's moons study their atmospheres
and measure tidal forces believed to
keep salt water oceans beneath warm and
liquid
could life like that found around deep
sea vents on Earth exist on the moon's
orbiting our giant distant neighbor or
are we all alone well watch this space
Tom Clark Sky News